people of the internet retro raconteur
here your guide to family-friendly
content in the world of video games in
today's video I'm gonna tell you where
to find all 9 stamps and also give you a
little preview of what the rewards are
for locating every single one of them
[Music]
tonight I greet you on this stormy
stormy evening here in retro land as we
talk all about the brand-new
international museum day event so to
participate in the stamp rally event
it's actually pretty straightforward you
just need to head over to the museum and
talk to blathers to kick things off now
I've already started things off in my
game what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go
around and show you guys where to find
all of the stamps now you're gonna have
three in each section of the museum to
find three and the bug section three in
the fossil section and three in the fish
section there are not any stamps at
least at this time in the art gallery so
if you're a frequent visitor of the
museum these shouldn't prove too
difficult right when you walk into the
fossil section you will see one here on
your laughters go up press a and you
will see that this is the stamp spot for
aquatic reptiles
[Music]
collect your stamp and then proceed on
through the area you're gonna stay in
the same room and head over to the far
right just before you go through the
door this one's kind of hiding a little
bit but it should be pretty easy for you
to spot right there go ahead and
interact with that one and you will find
your second stamp spot go ahead and
proceed into the next room on your right
and you will find yet another easy stamp
this one is the third and final stamp in
the fossil period waiting for it's gonna
be about halfway down the room right in
the middle go ahead and interact with
that stamp as well and you will complete
your fossil section now it's up to you
how you want to handle things from here
you can go talk to blathers now and
receive your first reward I just went
ahead and did all three sections and
then went and talked to him to get
everything all at once but it is
completely up to you you do not have to
do it in any set order alright so let's
go ahead and head over to the bug
section next
this one not gonna be quite as easy as
the first but still shouldn't prove too
difficult for you you're gonna just
gonna head right over here on the left
and you will find your first stamp here
go ahead and interact and you will find
the stamp spot for the quiet bench all
right so from the quiet finch location
each one they head back to your right
toward the entrance of the area and then
right here you wanna head up instead and
you're gonna follow this little path
here don't go across the bridge there
just go through these doors Skorpion up
the stairs and then this one kinda
hiding a little bit right there in front
of the screen though being blocked a
little bit by the railing of the stairs
this is the stamp spot for the lab go
ahead and collect your stamp there and
then we will move on to the butterfly
garden all right so for the next stamp
butterfly guard you're just gonna head
all the way to the left and then go down
right here through these doors and
you'll find the nice lovely fountain
here for the aptly named butterfly
garden go ahead and interact with your
stamp over here at the front of the room
and you'll now receive the stamp spot or
butterfly guard
[Music]
and last but not least we're gonna head
up over to the fish area of the museum
so you actually won't find any in this
first room here and even if you had all
the way to the right you won't find any
in there either instead what you want to
do is just go ahead and take an
immediate left right after you enter
that first section of the fish area and
then you're gonna see one on your right
here this one's very obvious you can't
miss it
go ahead and interact with that one and
you will receive the stamp spot for the
coast after you've got the coast go
ahead and head up the stairs here you
can take the stairs all the way up to
the top and then you will find your
second stamp this one is called coral
reef and then your final stamp is not
far at all from here you're just gonna
head to the right follow the little ramp
down and there it is all three of those
are located fairly close together this
was gonna be for icc and that will
complete a stamp rally with the
exception of your rewards of course go
ahead back to the front of the museum
and talk to blathers now you have to
talk to him three separate times in
order to receive all three of your
rewards but once you do you will receive
a plaque for each section of the museum
that you completed unfortunately he
won't be able to throw them down on the
ground and see what they look like right
away instead you'll need to head home so
you can hang them up on the wall and get
a nice look at the three plaques you
just completed all right if you guys
collected all the stamps and received
all three plaques be sure to give me a
thumbs up on the video and with that
congratulations you have completed the
Animal Crossing new horizons
International Museum
to a stamp rally give yourself a pat on
the back and enjoy those three plaques
that you just received from blathers if
there are any other updates on this
event and if we find out anything else
at all about potential future
opportunities we will be sure and let
you guys know with another video you can
also check out my twitch streams at
twitch.tv slash retro raconteur but for
now that's gonna be it for me I will
talk to you again soon thank you so much
for watching